- [Kelly] Ya'll both
have such a great song.
You know each other?
- [People] Yes we do.
- I was like, if that's how
you embrace a stranger, it's incredible.
(audience laughing)
Well, how's your new year going?
- My new year's going...
I'm just...
I'm on a Kelly Clarkson show, come on.
(Kelly exclaiming in excitement)
(audience cheering)
It started very, very well.
- It started off well, yeah.
- Beautiful. No, it's an
amazing New Year for me.
I feel like I'm living into the dreams
I had as a kid now.
- Beautiful.
- [Ami] You know?
And so, when that happens in your life,
and now you're in a
realities, it's very strange.
You're just trying to stay in the moment
as much as possible and take it in.
- Take it in, yeah.
So what do you think,
like, playing Dr. King,
like, what did that teach you?
Like, what did you learn from that?
(indistinct)
- As much as I'm having a great year now,
last year was crazy difficult.
Had loads of losses, and family losses.
And when I was actually...
When I was playing the character,
one of my favorite
speeches by him was, like,
"Any man I'd like to live a long life,
longevity has his place.
But I'm not worried with that now,
I'm trying to do god's will."
And that really shaped my life, actually.
Kind of leaning into that,
you're not gonna always be in
control of things, you know?
Things change a lot.
- Isn't it freeing, though,
when you let go of that?
When you try and...
- You let go of it,
and you just...
You allow life and whatever you believe in
to guide you in a new way.
So that was...
That's what I've kind of taken from
having the honor of playing
Dr. King, you know? It's...
- I know. Did you feel, like...?
- Scared?
- [Kelly] (laughs) Yeah.
- Yeah! Yeah!
- I was like...
If somebody was just like,
"I want you to play..."
I would be like, "No!"
- Yeah, no, I'm a British
boy from North London.
You know, you're like, "Oh, my goodness,
they want me to play Dr. King?"
But, you know, I got
really blessed, lucky.
George C. Wolfe saw
something in me, and...
- [Kelly] Very talented as well.
Talent had to do with it.
- That's kind of you.
It's very kind of you. And it was like...
You know, it was that opportunity
to step into what you've been trying
to cultivate your entire life.
You're an actor, you know?
We work, and we're waiting for that moment
to really step into something powerful,
and to play someone that is iconic,
but find a grounded way of
kind of attaching to them.
You found that with
Aretha, I'm sure, right?
- Yeah, yeah, that was...
So it was definitely that moment for me.
- Well, we're celebrating
music as a movement,
so music's...
But that's gotta be important
in your life, right?
- [Ami] Oh, music. Everything.
- You're too passionate!
You came out here,
I was like, "He likes music."
- As soon as they hit the
thing, I was like, "Oh, what?"
- So what do you like to listen to?
- Oh, my taste is eclectic. From, like...
We can go, like, Fela Kuti...
(Jennifer grunting in surprise)
We can go, you know, GIXX. We can...
(Ami laughing)
- She made a sound.
An actual, just guttural sound.
- Marvin Gaye. Listen,
I did musicals as a kid.
Like, I played Little Sammy
Davis Jr. in "The Jolson Story."
And Oliver. I'm actually...
My next film as a director
will be directing a musical.
- [Kelly] Oh, my gosh, that's awesome!
(Ami tongue-clucking)
- Okay. Alright. I see you.
(people laughing)
- [Kelly] Wait, that's incredible!
- You know me!
- [Kelly] Is this...?
- Gotta put pressure on her now!
(people exclaiming in excitement)
- [Kelly] Wait, is this one
of the dreams you're saying
you've had since you were a kid,
that you're now getting to step into?
- Yeah. I got an opportunity to direct
my first feature film
a year-and-a-half ago.
And I'm getting another
opportunity to direct, like,
a much bigger feature film,
and it's set around music,
It's set around music, and...
Yeah, so, I'm excited.
Like, and in it is kind of
"Portuguese Love" by Teena Marie.
(Jennifer exclaiming in surprise)
(indistinct)
- [Kelly] She leaned! She did a...
(Kelly laughing)
- And I... Your voice would be perfect.
(indistinct)
(people applauding)
- I know. You're now offering this,
and I wanna introduce her
singing at the Oscars.
We're just putting
in our things.
- It's just happening.
Like, we'll make it happen.
- We're putting in.
our things, yes.
- Wait, I heard that when you were a kid,
you were around, like, 11
when you worked with Michael
Jackson? That's crazy!
- So it was 1996. Mel's 11 years old,
and I'm there like, "Oh, my gosh."
Like here, like, "Oh, my
god, this is amazing."
And this guy comes up and goes,
"Alright, Michael
Jackson's about to come in.
Nobody talk to Michael.
Don't even look at Michael!
Don't even..." And I'm like, "Okay."
So all of a sudden, the doors open.
(Ami mimicking door opening)
And this guy comes in...
- And you hear...
(Kelly mimicking Michael
Jackson's singing)
And it's like...
(people laughing)
- There's bodyguards all around him.
He's in this white robe. He's
coming through like this.
- Of course he's in a robe.
And then, all of a sudden,
he jumps on the stage.
(Ami mimicking shoes
clattering on the floor)
I'm like, "Oh, my gosh."
And then, he leans down
to me, and he goes,
"Why is everybody so quiet?"
And he has a deep voice.
- [Kelly] What?
- Michael Jackson
actually had a deep voice.
(Jennifer laughing)
I was like...
And he goes, "Hi, my name is Michael",
I'm like, "Yeah, I know."
- [Kelly] "I'm aware."
(people laughing)
"Yeah, I'm aware. I can't look
at you, sir." You're like...
- So that was the Brit Awards 1996,
famously when Jarvis Cocker came on stage.
- Oh, my gosh, you were there!
- I was the little boy in the...
(indistinct)
- [Kelly] Wait, what happened?
- That's so crazy! Of course!
- [Ami] Yeah, it was me!
- Wait, what happened?
- Oh my, I did not know that!
- Yes! I was there.
I've been around for a while.
- I didn't see it!
Someone tell me what happened?
(audience laughing)
- You can watch it on YouTube, everyone.
- Oh, my gosh.
- I'm there. I'm a little
boy, I've got a turban on,
and I'm standing right
next to Michael Jackson.
Jarvis Cocker jumps on stage.
He's singing the "Earth Song."
And he shows his...
I don't know if we can say this.
Bottom? Is that okay to say?
- [Jennifer] Yep.
- Shows his ass.
- Bottom.
(people laughing)
Shows his ass.
And kind of mocking Michael Jackson.
Then everybody jumps on stage,
and running around, and...
The bottles flew, and people
got hit in their face, and...
- It was wild.
- It was crazy, and I was one of the kids
that didn't get hit, but I
cried like I did get hit,
'cause I thought, "I
could get a deal here."
(people laughing)
Like, "Something could
happen." I was like,
"Oh! I'm hurt too!"
- [Kelly] "Oh, my god!
I'm injured! Where's my money?"
- And Michael Jackson ended
up taking all those kids
to a place called Brent Cross
Shopping Centre, for any...
- [Jennifer] Nice.
- You would know.
And got everybody PlayStations.
- What?
- I never got the
PlayStation, but you know...
(people laughing)
- Sorry!
- [Ami] You know?
- Well, we need to do a short
commercial break, everybody.
You can see "Rustin" on Netflix.